The veil has been lifted on Val! The mysterious
MCU figure gets grounded in "Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever" — here's how the sequel
helps set up a new squad of anti-heroes.
Phase Four of the Marvel Cinematic Universe has
largely occupied itself with reshuffling the
pack. Many of the heroes who survived the Infinity
Saga became respected elder superhero statesmen,
and new heroes and legacy characters like
Yelena Belova and Kate Bishop emerged.
Among the more interesting Phase Four arrivals is
Contessa Valentina Allegra de Fontaine , aka Val.
"Don't call me that."
"Copy."
The Contessa is a mysterious figure
who's waltzed across various movies
and Disney+ shows like Nick Fury back in the day.
Kevin Feige himself confirmed early
on that Val's various appearances
are indeed building toward something,
and that something has since turned
out to be the new superhero team in the
MCU ... provided that you want to call
the antagonist-filled Thunderbolts lineup
"heroes" in the classic sense of the word.
The main difference between Nick Fury and the
Contessa is, of course, that everyone knows who
Fury is, while Val has gone through some pains
to keep everything but her full name and title
of nobility hidden from the viewer. Affable as
she may seem, she's still clearly tough as nails,
and just ominous enough that you can't be
quite sure whether she's a hero or a villain.
"Black Panther: Wakanda Forever"
continues Val's patchwork storyline
by finally revealing something concrete
about the mysterious Contessa. The viewers
find out that she's the director
of the MCU's version of the CIA,
and the ex-wife of the previously most
prominent Agency character, Everett Ross.
This explains a lot of Val's actions
over the course of Phase Four,
and how she has the sway and know-how to pull
her power moves over the various super-people
we've seen so far. Most importantly, "Black
Panther: Wakanda Forever" finally reveals in
no uncertain terms just how Val will
be able to start the Thunderbolts.
"We're not going to need a Captain
America. We're going to need a U.S. Agent."
"Wakanda Forever" makes clear
that unlike the high-tech,
superpowered world of Nick Fury's SHIELD,
the CIA is a far more mundane and secretive
spookshow — and its director reflects this.
While Fury is basically a superhero himself,
Val seems to prefer classic behind-the-scenes
espionage methods and deceptively easy banter
that hides her true intentions. She's so good
at this that she runs rings around Everett Ross,
who not only knows Val very well, but is
also a highly capable CIA operative himself.
Val's connections and position as the CIA director
put her in the perfect place to seek out and put
together a team like the Thunderbolts. Depending
on how you want to view it, she definitely seems
practical or amoral enough to tinker with a lineup
that consists of antagonists and gray-area players
like The Winter Soldier, Yelena Belova, U.S.
Agent, Red Guardian, Ghost, and Taskmaster.
With the Agency's assets at her disposal, she
also has little problem tracking them down.
As for who may very well appear in the
"Thunderbolts" movie, Thaddeus "Thunderbolt" Ross,
Val has connections to him as well. Even if
the high-ranking general and Secretary of
State would somehow have managed to avoid the
director of the CIA in a professional context,
the fact that Everett and Thaddeus have both been
affiliated with the Joint Counter Terrorist Centre
pretty much guarantees that Val and Thunderbolt
have ran into each other at some point.
It's hard to think of a better position
for Val than the head of the CIA,
and now that "Black Panther: Wakanda
Forever" lets the cat out of the bag,
it'll be interesting to see how she wields
her considerable power. Hey, she could even
turn out to be a Skrull or Madame Hydra, like in
the comics. How surprised would Everett Ross be?